vi togliete dall altro lato spiega c'è
una punizione tornare ha visto in vita
tutta la puntata trovare mai fatto lo
sarebbe una personalità quindi questa è
la prima volta facciamo questa fu questo
fa capire che questo format procedere
persone per quello che sono operanti a
luci su non possiamo lo vedresti campano
ma quando la piccola sosta non c'è che
dire una parola uno specchio mi ha detto
che amanda qui a mia madre tenevo molto
perciò gli americani a terra e 600 mm
teorica fermi
noi naturalmente abbiamo una soglia di
attenzione pary veramente riguarda
quella dello specchio di rivali vermi
center 89 20 a proposito dello specchio
dirigenza interrotto approvati 12
arrivano mia madre di mente inizia a
rincorrere voci per uccidersi novità ha
messo in questa situazione per
sopravvivere dachan batte mestoli e con
degli amici di letto dove in quel
periodo erano le palle di certi
contenuti che sono rimasti interpreting
e sempre con degli aneddoti simpatici
ragazzi bentornati una nuova puntata di
vita buttata qui sul mio canale il tema
della puntata di oggi è cazzate fatte da
bambini per questa puntata ho deciso di
imitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia
forse la cazzata più grande che ho fatto
da piccolo che è stata quella lì di non
eliminare tre persone che sono nate a
distanza di pochi anni da da me i miei
tre fratelli gabriele e gianluigi
enrico salve voi non sapete come
funziona questo certo che lo sappiamo un
vino mai detto fino a 2 secondi non
abbiamo qua dentro visto che non mi e
mai invitato a o cerca per esempio di
avere ospiti simpatici della vista che
potete permettervi tutti insieme alla
volta che abbiamo più di un ospite cioè
credo che in tre parti un cervello che
sono sempre tre ciao senz'altro la cosa
più assurda è che ormai si è tenuto da
una persona che conosco da tempo di mio
padre da piccolo ha perso una pallina e
cercandolo sotto il divano nel nulla
sotto il divano prendono cellino e inizi
a farlo cela sotto il divano ha preso
fuoco
mi cercava di spegnere il fuoco con la
casetta di plastica dello won the thing
discontinuità smi chiude ma una pallina
testicolo ha perso bruxelles nero
all'animo che se poi c'è che possa
essere garbato ha detto una pallina una
pallina testicolo ragazzi ma è ovvio che
ha aperto l'ovetto kinder si è persa al
camere gente
mangiare io veramente un livello
[Musica]
io chiedo perdono per il livello
bassezza quelli che saranno questi una
volta quando avevo 7 8 anni molti cio
come sorella sono state chiuso da lei
dentro mia toretto sotto la mia porta
che la camera era fatta di vetro
sfondato la porta non mi riporto piero
oggetto
[Risate]
naturalmente noi vogliamo bene alla
kinder mangiamo solo timber che voglia
di quello della pace comunque non è
fatta di cazzate dio hoc fatto tu sei
reti ragazzo che è già qualcosa non ti
conosce gli oggetti video arrivare da
una volata sireno bene si sta ricordando
un periodo in cui ero fissato con le
sirene mi stava cucendo la coda non si
stava cucendo lui era andato in acqua
facendo finta di essere un sereno e
c'era gianluigi che doveva fare complice
sulla scaletta prima che è propriamente
quelle vocali
io mettevo una bella donna di 90 anni le
bucce di banana terra per farsi curare
perché quando abbiamo visto hanno
giocato a survivor stavano in un balcone
naturalmente con la porta aperta proprio
nome di centrare in casa fingevano che
dovevano vivere lì a un certo punto che
si sono messi a pisciare nei vasi del
balcone perché perché gli scappava la
pipì cia comunque come che nostra madre
non è finita non so in un ospedale
psichiatrico ancora non si sà passati ma
meglio le sirene meglio fare la sirena
al mare o pisciare nel vaso di fron
scusate che già stiamo facendo ecco due
follie diversi io ero un sognatore avete
problemi alla prova come compagno prese
dal bagno con una penna un pezzo di
daiwa termici e sotto il banco di
un'altra mia compagna spiedino che
appunto andando a prendere la scossa da
sotto al banco si ritrovò il grembiule
sporco di mentre noi facevamo la cacca
la piccolina mi fa don lurio nella nato
mourinho hanno fatto con quel periodo lì
non quando uno gli scappava
non è che ti alzavi tutti spostati così
in modo da dare lo spazio filo di
lasciare dietro e tutti a mettere la
firma sulla chiave come abbiamo anche
quelle derivate chicca berici più
livelli
no e gianluigi lama ma io ero piccolo
piccolo e mai pubblico da qualcuno mi
dava non mi ricordo io avevo circa 45
anni pur di farmi regalare le caramelle
mi ha passato le mutande e facevo vedere
mie parti intime basta recarsi sempre
fermi un attimo si e dal balcone anche
gabriele malediceva dal balcone
dal conto piano diciamo ed eroi epici e
baci sconfiggendo anche adesso
[Risate]
ciao per quanto riguarda la grande
riguarda le cazzate fatto da piccolo
ecco io quando quando ero piccolo ci sta
una festa era d'estate cioè la sesta nel
paese che vive immagina tutta la filiera
troviamo di gente capo delle braccia
della mamma mi dirigo verso il centro
dell'anfiteatro salvo sullo stemma del
paese ne abbassa i pantaloni e
incomincia a pisciare davanti a tutti
sono un commento anche di una vaga briga
bnp scilla sono universali famiglie di
quando una cosa tipo non far rivivere
non fallire quando lo dice una cosa con
con gli occhi che vanno per senso
nell'istante in cui allora vediamo
allora di cazzate fatte tante
però diciamo che trovi cari rilevanti
con i fratelli dipingevo un animale così
a scelta un giorno decidemmo di fare
decadere mettemmo a mangiare l'erba del
nostro giardino
la cosa si concluse che io mangio in
ortica e quindi può immaginare che un po
come come la bresaola finge di essere i
dinosauri e mangiavate la bresaola coi
piedi
no no no arrivare al corretto all'osso
io sono l'uomo senza impronte digitali e
l'iphone un regista d'impronta eppure
non siamo andati a fare il passaporto e
li di prendere di impronta digitale lui
e lui ha cambiato vita perché non
funziona neanche una è quella lo ha
fatto che brutte molti trucchi le mani
la poliziotta
mamma mia che brutta che non c'entrano
cazzata ragazzini comunque allora mi
chiamo l'allenamento di questa casa è la
tecnica di è bellissimo perché devo
vedere invece vorranno che ha fatto
luigi infatti calcola che i nostri
verrati dalle impronte digitali dovete
una maglietta abbiamo messo allo smalto
per unghie sono le sindromi una nostra
compagna di classe
ovviamente una tesi atleta che gli
faresti mettere l'audio dell'intervista
chi sta parlando grazie ciao
ma io sono di noi tutti insulare censura
[Risate]